Hello and welcome to this video on montages.
Now we're going to use a key press in order to trigger a montage being played on a character.
We're just going to use a waving animation in this instance, because it's one of the easiest ones to create.
But you can understand that this could be used for any attack or rolls,
or any other animation that you want your character to use on command.
So the first thing that I'm going to want to do is create a new animation.
And I'm going to do this by editing an animation that already exists.
So I'm going to come in to the content drive and search for idle.
Now you can see here we have the mm underscore idle.
I'm just going to duplicate this and copy it into our directory.
Now I'm going to take this and I'm just going to rename it by pressing F2.
I'm going to rename it to mm underscore waving.
If I double click to open this up, we open up a specific interface to do with the animations.
You can see here we have a viewport which will show us the animation at any one point.
And below this we have a timeline that's going to show us where we are in the timeline for this animation.
Now I've got a couple of controls and I can stop, pause and replay.
I'm going to start off by pausing this here.
Now I'm going to want to edit this animation.
And in order to do that, I am going to need to be able to see the bones so I can move them around.
So the first thing I want to do is come up to character and we have a selection for bones.
And I'm going to change this from select only to all hierarchy.
And now we can see the bones that we have to work with.
And my goal is to create a simple waving animation.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to come down in and I'm going to start off with the upper arm left.
And I'm going to rotate that up a little bit and out a little bit.
This does not need to be perfect.
Then I'm going to grab the lower arm and move that up to see if it looks natural.
OK, that doesn't look terrible. Maybe move it back a little bit.
And I might make the hand face out.
I'm scrolling down on the mouse wheel so that I can be very accurate with the movements.
I'm going to grab the bottom of the hand and make it out a little bit.
There you go. So I'm quite happy with the bone that I have here.
Now, in order to save this, I'm going to want to push the plus key at the bottom.
This will add a bone transform additive track.
See, now that we can see that we have an additive track for all of the different bones that we moved at this point.
Now, you'll see that that is just an additive track consistent across all of these.
I'm going to want to add a second one in in order to get this hand to move.
So I'm moving it a little bit further in here.
I'm going to come back down to this arm and I'm going to rotate it to the other side.
And I'll rotate the hand slightly so that we are still in an upward motion.
And again, I'm going to hit the plus key here.
It creates just another track. So you can see we have a very small hand move.
What I'll do is I'll jump back to a little bit after it and move the hand back.
I'll move the hand back and the arm back to its nearest original position.
Now I'm going to push the plus key again.
So a relatively simple arm wave movement.
Now, this idle is actually quite a long animation.
So in order to cut this down, I'm going to move on to around 90.
Right hand click. I'm going to remove frame 90 to 228.
Now we've got a far shorter animation.
So if I just hit play, you can see we have a very, very small animation.
I'm leaving a little bit of an in and a little bit of an out
because we'll have a bit of a blend when we are running the montage.
Again, this doesn't need to be perfect.
We just need something to work with so that we can demonstrate this.
So I'm now going to hit save and jump back into the content browser here.
Now we cannot directly run this animation from the Character Blueprint.
In order to do this, we're going to need to use a montage.
So I'm going to come in right hand click.
And again, under animation, I'm going to select animation montage.
I will select the SK mannequin.
And I'm going to call this mont underscore wave.
If I double click on this montage that I've just created,
you can see, again, we get a very similar setup to what we previously had with the animation.
Now I have an asset browser down the right hand side.
And I'm going to use this to find my wave.
So if I type in WAV, see I've got my wave.
I could drag this in and place this on the default group.
Now, there are a number of other things that you can do with montages.
This doesn't necessarily need to be a singular animation.
It could actually grab another animation, for example, the full animation.
And I could drag this in and connect the two together.
So you can see here that these animations would play one after the other,
not necessarily naturally.
This gives you an example of how you might use a montage.
You could possibly use a combination of animations to all be played together.
And you can do things like add notifiers on this in order to trigger some logic connected to an animation.
But in our case, we're not going to do any of that.
We're just going to leave it with our mm underscore waving animation.
Really short, straightforward animation.
And I'm going to hit save.
What's worth noting is this is playing through the default group slot.
Slots can be added.
And that's useful if you want to have different montages run through different slots in the animation.
We'll demonstrate that in a minute.
So let's jump back into our animation blueprint.
And for this, I'm going to need to go back to the AmiGraph.
At present, we have a very simple animation.
All we have here is our locomotion state machine.
Now, I'm going to add in a bit more functionality.
I'm going to add in functionality that's going to sit between the locomotion machine and the output pose.
So to start with, I am going to hold down the Alt key and left click.
Now, our chart's going to get a little bit more complicated.
And we are going to need to reference the locomotion state machine multiple times.
At present, we cannot do that with the state machine as it is.
What we're going to need to do is save the output as a cached pose.
And to do this, I'm going to drag off the animation pose.
I'm going to search for cache.
And you can see here at the bottom, we have an option for new saved cache pose.
And I'm just going to set the name to saved locomotion.
So what this will allow us to do is have multiple reference to this saved locomotion.
This is almost like a variable where we're saving out the output of the state machine.
OK, and with that saved, I'm going to come back to the output pose.
And I'm going to right-hand click and search for use cached.
And that's going to allow us to have a used cached posed saved locomotion.
I'm going to need to have this twice.
So again, I'm going to control C copy and control V to duplicate this cached pose.
Now, the reason we're going to want to have this twice is because we are going to split the body into two sections.
We're going to have the upper half of the body and the lower half of the body.
This will allow us to run animations that would only affect one half of the body.
In this case, we're looking at the upper half.
And this is useful. For example, you have a character that can attack with a sword.
You don't necessarily want to take over the entire body to do it.
You might just want to take over the top half. That's what we're doing here.
And we're going to do that by using a layered blend per bone.
I'm just going to search for per bone. And you can see we have a layered blend per bone.
Now I will plug this output into the output pose.
I'm going to plug the saved locomotion into the base pose here.
And with this layered blend per bone selected, I'm going to come up into the details panel.
And what I want to do is tell it which bone to split the body on.
So under the layered setup, there is already a singular index here.
And if I do that a drop down, you can see we have a branch filter.
I'm going to push plus. And in this index, it's requesting a bone name.
For this, I'm going to use spine underscore zero one.
And if we were to jump back into our montage and onto our skeleton,
you can see that this is right at the bottom here.
So this is controlling the entire at the top path,
and then the legs are controlled with the other section.
So I've split this skeleton in two.
So the first section, so one of the things about a layered blend per bone,
is the first section is always going to be from root upwards.
So this is going to control the legs.
Now the second section, this is going to be from the rest of the skeleton.
So this is the top half of the body.
And I might want to play the saved locomotion.
However, I'm going to add a slot in the middle.
So if I come in here and I search for slot,
you can see under montage, we have an option for slot.
And it has default slot.
I'm going to drag this in and connect it up to the blend pose zero.
So this default slot is the same slot that we were running our montage in.
So in the case that the montage is running,
the default slot, because it comes after the locomotion,
is going to override the locomotion.
And this is going to send the montage data telling it to be played.
Then it's going to be split by the layered blend per bone
and given to the output pose.
So if nothing is running through the default slot,
we would get the saved locomotion.
However, if we run a montage, it's going to take over this default slot here.
So now if I save and compile, that's all working.
But we still need to run this animation.
So to do that, we're going to need to jump back into our third person character that we're using.
And here I am on the event graph.
I'm going to add in another section at the bottom here.
I'm going to come in here, right-hand click,
and I am going to search for KeyZ.
You see at the bottom here we have a keyboard event for Z.
So that gives us our keyboard event.
And on this, we just want to play a montage.
So I will select Play Ami Montage.
And I need to select the Ami Montage here.
I'm going for the wave.
And I'm also going to increase the play rate.
So I'm going to make that three just so it's a bit faster.
And now if I save and compile,
jump back in and play,
this is working.
You can see at the point that I press Z,
the hand starts waving.
And even if the character is moving,
if I press Z,
the animation just takes over the character.
So that now brings us to the end of the exercise,
as we can now trigger an animation
that we've created from a montage.
In the next video,
we're going to have a look at the original animation blueprint
and see how this is implemented slightly differently.
Thank you very much.